In the Netherlands,
a 55-year-old woman
visited her doctor with
a very strange complaint.
She was having spontaneous
orgasms from her feet.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey, friends.
Laci Green here for D News.
It's not every day that
you hear about someone
having orgasms from their feet.
But today, today
is a special day.
The woman is known
only as Mrs. A.
And according to her case
study released this week
by the Journal of
Sexual Medicine,
she was having sudden orgasmic
sensations five to six times
a day from her feet--
well, actually,
her foot, her left
foot, to be exact.
Now, I know some of you all
out there are probably feeling
pretty jolly right now.
Like, hey, I want foot orgasms.
But she actually hated it.
It would happen randomly,
without any sort
of sexual thoughts or arousal,
and who knows what company.
Imagine you're going
through your day,
and every other hour it's
like, really, another one?
The doctor said she
felt really embarrassed,
and she wanted it
to stop immediately.
So, what was going on?
Well, about a year before this
started, she was in a coma
because she had sepsis.
When she came out, she did
have some strange sensations
in that same foot
because of nerve damage.
Still, that shouldn't
cause orgasms in your feet.
So they did an MRI scan,
found nothing, did an EMG,
found nothing, put an electrical
current through her foot,
and then came the orgasms.
What they believe happened
is that her brain basically
got confused.
Sensory information from the
foot and from the genitals
enter the spinal cord
at the same time.
So after the nerves in
her foot regenerated,
the brain was no longer able
to tell them what was vagina
and what was left foot.
Your feet and your genitals
may be far apart on your body,
but in your brain,
they're like best buds.
Feet and the genitals sit
right next to each other
in the somatosensory
homunculus, which
is your brain's sensory map.
Add some neural crosstalk,
and bam, foot orgasms.
Fortunately, her fix
was swift and easy.
An injection of anesthetic
into her spinal nerve
cleared the problem up.
Interestingly to me,
this sensory map mix-up
also happens to be the
predominant explanation
for foot fetishes.
Feet are the single most common
non-genital sexual fetish
in the world.
In the same way that
someone else might
be aroused by genitals, a foot
fetishist is aroused by feet.
There have been lots of
other theories put forth
in the past about why feet are a
focus of so much sexual energy.
Perhaps it's a
forbidden fruit effect.
They're mysterious
and sexy because you
don't see feet as much.
Freud said it's because
feet look like a penis.
But then again, Freud thinks
everything looks like a penis.
Perhaps it's sexy
because we associate
with power and respect,
what with kissing or washing
someone's feet.
Kind of interesting
ideas, but still,
can't go wrong with
some solid neurology.
So since the curious case
of Mrs. A's foot orgasms,
the doctors believe it's
possible there are more people
out there struggling with
unwanted orgasms and shame.
So they've set up a website
about foot orgasm syndrome
to reach out and conduct
further research the matter.
So I'll link to that below.
Thanks for joining me, guys.
Don't forget to like
our D News Facebook
page before you bounce.
We post up extra science
bits there all week.
Bye bye.